bonjour à vous merci d'être en direct
avec nous ce matin alors cette
consultation publique a lancé par
l'autorité de sûreté nucléaire est ce
que vous la jugez utiles
de toute façon c'est une obligation
légale en vertu des conventions
internationales c'est la convention des
russes qui oblige toute décision ayant
un impact environnemental à faire
l'objet d'une participation du public
concerné donc tout à fait tout à fait
favorables comme dans le cadre des
éoliennes
en revanche je voudrais quand même
rappeler que les centrales nucléaires au
son des centrales totalement écologique
à la différence de ce que précise
greenpeace qui n'est plus qu'une piste
m'écrit noir puisque les centrales
nucléaires il dit que j'étais totalement
décarbonés 100 % de l'électricité venant
des centrales nucléaires est décarbonée
donc je ne vois pas pourquoi greenpeace
heures sans tête
sans faire dans son sa guerre contre le
nucléaire alors qu'elle devrait plutôt
lutter contre la pollution éoliennes qui
détruit notre environnement et nos
paysages
actuellement par ailleurs ce qui est
très important de préciser c'est que la
question des déchets nucléaires et ça
fait une question très importante et
réglé puisque gérard nous a eu le prix
nobel de physique en 2018 parce qu'il a
trouvé des techniques au laser
permettant de diminuer la radioactivité
des déchets nucléaires en passant de 1
million d'années à 30 minutes
donc je ne vois pas pourquoi on s'entête
à dénigrer et greenpeace en tête à
dénigrer le nucléaire peut-être le tout
pour défendre son business dans via sa
fille
à greenpeace énergie qui a fait d accord
avec les stars des partenariats avec des
stades pour développer la communication
sur les éoliennes partout dans le monde
donc là il ya un conflit d'intérêt
majeur et donc moi je m'insurge contre
cette guerre contre le nucléaire de
greenpeace qui devrait plutôt être
aujourd'hui de la part de greenpeace une
guerre contre la pollution et aux deux
guerres contre les attaques à la
biodiversité que produisent les
éoliennes qui sont intermittentes là au
delà justement de des conflits
d'intérêts que vous dénoncez vis-à-vis
de greenpeace ya quand même plusieurs
questions qui se posent cela concerne la
dépendance de notre pays vis-à-vis de
l'énergie nucléaire et se demander aussi
si l'énergie nucléaire c'est une énergie
d'avenir
c'est une énergie d'avenir parce
qu'aujourd'hui on lutte contre la
décarbonation or ce qu'il se passe c'est
que la france avec son hydraulique et
son électricité nucléaire faut savoir et
la championne du monde de la
décarbonation en vertu de l'électricité
au fait qu'on est le pays le plus
vertueux
n'en déplaise à greta comme berne nous
sommes le pays le plus vertueux en terme
d'émissions de gaz à effet de serre
d'ailleurs d'ailleurs vous prenez les
quatre les mappemondes de la et les
délits tdd et parleurs de d2 les
marmande 2 et rejets de gaz à effet de
serre et bien nous sommes en fait
puisque en fait nous sommes le pays le
plus vertueux
en outre grâce à notre électricité
nucléaire nous sommes totalement
indépendants et nous pouvons vendre
cette électricité verte au pays le
voisin donc je ne vois pas pourquoi il
faut s'endetter à dénigrer cette
électricité alors c'est une déficit est
parfaitement d'avenir et j'en veux pour
preuve c'est que la chine développe son
parc électronucléaire et tous les grands
pays le da racing également et donc
c'est bien les états unis donc s'il bien
que cette technologie
si on veut bien se donner
à peine de développer
les ingénieurs de former des ingénieurs
sur le thème et de bas faire en sorte
qu'il n'y ait plus de cas formés et
d'ingénieurs formés sur le thème est
bien le nucléaire est forcément quelque
chose d'avenir mais par contre l'éolien
dont on a 20 ans d'expérience et qui est
la responsabilité qui gallach porte la
lourde responsabilité de provoquer de
futures coupures d'électricité puisque
l'intermittence des éoliennes conduit à
cette à ces possibles coupures
d'électricité et bien en revanche il
faut stopper l'éolienne qui est une
électricité du passé en tout cas la
l'autorité de sûreté nucléaire pose une
autre question est ce que finalement
elle demande aussi que des travaux
soient réalisés sur les sites qui
pourraient être prolongées est-ce que
edf a les moyens de réaliser ces travaux
écoutez quand on voit quelle 150
milliards d'euros qui sont provisionnées
ou engagés pour les subventions aux
promoteurs éoliens 150 milliards d'euros
pour rien pour financer le bénéfice des
promoteurs éoliens
je pense qu on a moyen de trouver
l'argent ans en arrêtant les subventions
à l'éolien pour financer d'une part
effectivement la sûreté nucléaire donne
aux nos centrales nucléaires
et puis financé aussi la formation des
professionnels par des nuls de dans le
domaine nucléaire parce que en raison du
dénigrement depuis des années des années
et des années du nucléaire à cause de
structures comme greenpeace
et bien en fait on a perdu la compétence
et on a laisser cette compétence à des
pays comme la chine
donc il y a urgence à retourner des
professionnels a effectivement
entretenir nos centrales nucléaires a
développé des fonds et à dégager des
fonds pour cette électricité et je
rappelle par ailleurs
samantha que le il faut rappeler que
grâce à notre nucléaire la france à une
électricité parmi les moins chers du
monde et assure la compétitivité de
notre pays
dans les enjeux géopolitiques et
géostratégiques et assure également
l'indépendance et la souveraineté de
notre pays et pour dernière que les
votants pour autant est-ce qu'il faut
pas tout de même trouver aussi des
alternatives autres que l'éolienne parce
qu'on va pas vous convaincre sur ce
point c'est sur ce point là mais trouver
d'autres alternatives justement
l'énergie nucléaire écoutez à partir du
moment où c'est décarbonée donnez moi
une électricité d'origine décarbonés
aujourd'hui lorsqu'on prend les travaux
du giec et les travaux de différence
écologistes travers le monde
aujourd'hui tout le monde s'accorde à
dire et ça va se développer vers et dans
les mois les années qui viennent
s'accordent à dire que le nucléaire est
la seule électricité d'écart abonnés qui
permettent de lutter contre le
réchauffement climatique
en tout cas l'électricité la plus fiable
et la plus intéressante en la matière
alors c'est pas avec les panneaux
photovoltaïque ou l'éolien qui ont un
facteur de charge de fin pour cent par
rapport à leur capacité maximale de
production pour inviter à faire quelque
chose par ailleurs effectivement peu
développés l'hydrogène et d'autres
techniques totalement novatrice comme la
fission nucléaire et lépide développer
la recherche et développement mais c'est
pas en cautérisant la plaie avec des
éoliennes ou des panneaux
photovoltaîques on va changer la donne
en matière électrique
c'est vraiment binaisse d'ailleurs les
250 milliards d'euros qu'on a engagés
sur les éoliennes par exemple puisque en
fait c'est la mare comprendre à longueur
de médias et bien n'ont servi qu'à
produire 4 à 5% de l'électricité et un
pour cent de la totalité du de joie
énergique de notre petit merci beaucoup
à vous merci beaucoup à vous fabien bové
je rappelle que vous êtes essayiste
auteur de l'ouvragé éoliennes la face
noire de la transition écologique aux
éditions du rocher